welcome to this session on react.js
uh and today's session we are going to
focus on
the objectives of why would you want to
use react.js
as a technology to build scalable
web applications in today's session we
will also focus on the component based
design strategy
around react.js and how the strategy
focuses on
reusability of building single page
applications which are lightweight
quickly loadable
with reduced amount of waiting and
response time
for customers that would be accessing
your web application
in today's session let's start with
understanding the objectives of what
we're going to focus on purely we will
start with what react.js is all about
we'll then get into discussing the
features of react.js
we'll then move on to the components
that make up
the core structure of react.js we'll
discuss the various type of components
we'll then move on to understanding
props effective state management
event handling and we would close the
session with
event binding so what is react.js all
about it's a trending technology that
everyone's speaking about
based on scripting and it evolves around
this new age term called full stack web
development that we would do in today's
digital world so react.js is basically a
javascript based library
for building fast and interactive user
applications
for the web as well as for mobility
devices so it is basically a rad or a
rapid application development tool
that will assist with quickly setting up
a pattern based
application that's disciplined that's
flexible to change that's well designed
so that any changes coming from your
customer can
be incorporated very easily and the
changes can be isolated to one small
section of the code hence reducing the
effort that would be required to go
ahead and rebuild and test
the entire application again for every
change that comes in
via the customer's request it's again an
open source technology being based on
javascript the very fact that it creates
a set of components makes them reusable
which means that you can inject these
components on the page
as and when required and that really
promotes the reusability of the
application in the design
react.js is also basically maintained
by facebook and that is also what makes
it
really popular amongst developers let's
explore some of the core features
of this technology the first concept
that we're going to speak about
the first feature that we're going to
speak about focuses around jsx
which is a syntax extension to
javascript it is basically used with
react
to describe what the user interface
should look like
so by using the jsx or the syntax
extension
it is now possible to write html
structures in the same file
that also go and contain the javascript
code but still
ensuring the right level of segregation
between
the script and the html in order to keep
the code legible
maintainable and flexible to change the
other important aspect of react.js
is the virtual dom the generic dom is
released by w3c and is an api that
allows us to create dhtml pages
react keeps a lightweight representation
of the real dom which it calls the
virtual dom which actually
wraps the w3c dom api or the dom tree
structure
that exists on your html page so
manipulating the real dom
is much slower than actually
manipulating the virtual dom which is
the
wrapper layer on which the react.js api
operates so when the state of an object
changes the virtual dom
changes only that object in the real dom
instead of updating
all the objects and this saves a lot of
time because rather than
actually going and generating a full
tree shake
and recreating the entire dom tree
structure of the page
working at the virtual dom has this
added benefit that react.js comes with
where it does not need to do a complete
dom tree
rewrite for any update that dynamically
you would want to do
on the page the architecture that
react.js uses
in a model view controller based
architecture react
sits at the view which is now
responsible for how the application
looks and feel in an mbc architecture
the controller will map to the
functional flow of the application
and the model will map data store or the
data mapping mechanism in your app while
the view
works and maps to the html templates
that are rendered on the screen
so mvc is an architectural pattern that
separates the application into three
layers the model
which looks at the focuses on the data
the data mapping the entity model
the view which focuses on the html
templates and the controller that maps
to the functional flow of that use case
so the model
would relate to the data the view to the
ui and the controller acts
as a super user and allows us to
transmit
data between the model and the view this
makes data binding a very crucial
feature of react.js and reacts one way
data binding
keeps everything modular and fast so
once you have your data
set up in the model you obviously would
want to take that data and
represent it inside the view so this
unidirectional data flow
in react would mean that when designing
a react app you would often
nest child components within parent
components to ensure you have a healthy
and an intelligent data sharing strategy
so
i could have a shopping cart component
which would have a list of
line items within it and that would be
an example
of a nested component sharing data and
information among themselves
next comes the extensions so react goes
beyond simple ui
and has many extensions for complete
application architecture support
these extensions also would provide
server-side rendering and support mobile
app development
and hence react can also be extended
with flux and redux
among other third-party extension apis
that support this entire ecosystem so
the very fact that we today built using
the javascript language is because we
can go ahead and create hybrid
applications that can then also be
ported
uh as installable apps on mobility
platforms
the debugging for react is extremely
easy to do because
of the large developer community and
support with plugins and facebook also
provides
a small browser extension that makes
debugging for react
applications faster and easier to do
coming to the components
which is the core aspect of what
react has to offer and it's very
essential that we build the right
component design in the application to
ensure that transmitting data
and the information flow between various
components
is really smooth in terms of its
execution and it's well designed
and this is the crux of the single page
application that we designed today
where you really do not navigate the
user to different pages but you just
inject a set of components into the page
and remove them
when not required creating an illusion
for the end user that the customer is
actually going
and navigating across different pages so
coming to components they are actually
the building
blocks of a react application that
represent a part of the user interface
so if you look at the facebook website
itself this would be split up into
different
components so there would be a login
component that would take care of the
credential management there would be
another component that looks at
registering users
the company logo and uh the connect and
share
that you see would also be a different
set of components that could be
injected as and when required onto the
page so the sign up the image component
the icon component all of these are
split into several small sections
of code blocks which can be tested
separately
and then added onto your consolidated
page so the components basically promote
reusability
where a component that is used in one
area of the application can also be
reused in another area with
updated data and this is what actually
helps speed up the entire
development process in react you can
also nest components within the
each other for example in a e-commerce
application
with a retail store i could have a
shopping list component that could
further have a
a set of products within it and a
product
component could actually further nest a
product detail component inside it and
this is what
and how the entire application structure
can be designed with nested
components the render method is one of
the most important
and it is in its minimal form basically
a component must define this method
which actually specifies how this
component would go and render
onto the dom tree and ultimately the
browser from
passing properties between components
which is again
a very core aspect of react where
components would communicate with each
other
by transmitting data in terms of
properties
and a component can also receive props
and
these are basically data points or data
values that are passed
by the parent to specify certain values
from the parent to the child component
components are further categorized
into certain categories that we are
going to talk about so there are
stateless functional components
and stateful class components now what
do these mean
we'd focus on the state list first now
these are javascript functions which
basically return
a stream of html and they can be
contained
in a js or a jsx extensions
files then we've got stateful class
components now these are regular classes
that extend the component class
and they must contain a render method
that should return a stream of html
and again they can be contained within a
gs or jsx file
so a stateless functional component
would not really hold any state in terms
of
data values and will just return a
static stream of html on the other hand
a stateful class
would also do state management by
storing some amount of data along with
it
and then bind that into the html view
which would be rendered on the ui
let's talk about props or properties now
components can pass
properties from the parent component to
the nested or the inner
child component properties actually help
making components more dynamic because
due to the data binding and the state
that the properties hold
you can actually flash certain amount of
updated values
into the user interface or the
components that are being
injected onto the ui it's hence
important to define
all these props their data types and
also
their default values props in a
component
cannot be changed let's talk about state
management next
which is the value that most of the
components
would hold at any given point of time
when your application is functional
we are back again to the facebook
landing page where we see
the login component and let's consider a
scenario here
where when a user logging into facebook
clicks on the login icon
without entering any credentials so what
would happen
obviously the login would fail and the
color of the login icon
changes and a sudden alert symbol
appears
instructing the user to perform a
different action and prompting the user
to first register into facebook before
attempting to login because that's not a
valid user id that probably would be
registered with facebook
now these actions are facilitated by
react
with the help of states and that is what
makes
uh state management a very crucial
aspect
of the react framework so a state object
stores the values of properties
belonging to
a component so if i have a login
component the current state of that
component
could be successfully logged in or
denied
login these would be different valid
states for
a property belonging to a component so
this state can be modified based on some
user
action or based on some network changes
so every time the state of some data
changes react
would re-render the component into the
browser
the state object is initialized in the
constructor of the component
which is a function that automatically
triggers when the component is
object is initialized the state object
can also store
multiple properties so multiple property
values can be assigned and this dot
set state is a method used to change the
value
of the state object the set state
function performs
a shallow merge between the new state
that you provide
and the previous state let's talk about
event handling
now events are going to be the
notification or triggers
or user performed actions that would
trigger
the state in a component to get modified
so every application revolves around
handling and listening to events
in order to do something else in
response so
in response to an event you can perform
an action so
event handling with react follows two
major conventions
reactive ends are named using camel
casing rather than
lower case so camel casing would have
the first letter
of the word in lowercase and the second
major letter in uppercase
with gsx you can pass a function as the
event handler
rather than a string so entire function
expression
can be passed as a parameter to the
event handler and not just
flat string values so here if you look
at the code
you see an html button on the click of a
button
that's the camel casing for the on click
registration
equal to we've passed a function which
is called
display message which will be executed
when the button is clicked
and that display message plays the role
of an event handler now it's time to
understand
event binding so along with the
notifications that you subscribe to so
that you would come to know
where users have clicked or what
interaction has happened in your
component you may also want to send
data or information along with this
event so event binding tells the browser
which function is called when a
particular event occurs and what kind of
data you would want to send across
so event binding in is basically what
you achieve in react
using these following steps the first
step is
you would find the handler in the render
method by using
a keyword called as this so this is a
system defined keyword
in react which is used to bind the event
handler
inside your render method the arrow
functions
in the render method can also be used to
do
event binding the arrow function is now
an ecmascript standard which
also makes it a javascript standard and
hence
the arrow function is very similar to
the lambda operators etcetera that you
have
in other programming languages like c
sharp so binding the event handler
in the constructor is also another step
or another
mode by which the event binding can be
achieved
the arrow function as a class property
can also be
implemented to do the binding let's move
to a hands-on demo to
understand how do we set up a basic
application using components
using nested components using props or
properties
understanding state management and doing
event binding
and event subscription to set up a
simple
react.js application so let's start with
creating a simple demo on react.js
and we are going to create a simple
application
that will connect to an online music
streaming service called spotify
and we will call our application music
app so
let's get started the first step is to
first get the node.js
platform and server installed to do that
let me go to google
and let's just type node.js and here is
the website nodejs.org there are two
versions available
the lts which is the stable version and
the current
we'll prefer the stable so we'll click
on that and you can see we have an
option
which is called save file the moment
this file is saved to the disk
we just need to double click on it and
keep clicking on the next button to get
it installed
on our system and we also have a
documentation
available here so which explains most of
the features
of the node platform and there are
binaries available for different os's
mac windows
etc so you can select the right bitness
32-bit 64-bit
and the right os and then go ahead
and download the specific uh version
that suits your platform and
you can see here that there are
different there are also help files
available that will allow you to
go through the installation documents
for node.js installation on linux
etc so to start with i'm opening up the
command prompt
and here is where we're going to call
the node package manager
using the note package manager which is
pre-installed with
your standard node.js installation we
will
initialize our react application so
we would say react dash app and
we want to now go and create an
application called
music app in this folder so as a
prerequisite for the demo
all we need to do is install node.js
from
node.js.org the official website just
download it
and install it and that's when you open
the command prompt you fire npm which
stands for note package manager init for
initialize
react dash app is a standard keyword to
initialize and create
a skeletal structure of a react.js
application and the name of the app
is music app so we'll hit enter we'll
give this
some time and you can see it's started
downloading the core
react.js libraries and it is attempting
to create
our application so it's installing all
the prerequisite packages and scripts
that are required
initialize and create a new react.js
application called
music app now once this application is
created all we would require
is an online editor so you could use an
offline or an on-premise editor as well
so any editor of your choice
it could be atom or sublime text or
webstorm
and for this demo we're going to use
visual studio code which is a free
editor
available by microsoft and you can just
google for visual studio code
again uh this is not visual studio
professional edition etc that we use for
building our c sharp or mbc based
applications this is a lightweight
editor for building javascript-based
footstep
full applications so so while this
installs
let's go and take a look at visual
studio code so this is the visual studio
code
editor and this is the editor that we've
installed directly downloaded from
visualstudiocode.com and
installed it and all we need to do is
open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it
we just say file open folder and we
would open that folder
within our visual studio code editor so
we'll give it a while
until that application gets generated
and once it's created
we will again implement the component
based design and architecture
and the data flow between the components
and we also look at connecting to a live
data source which is a json set of
characters that we would consume which
is a restful service
the set of music tracks exposed as a
restful api
endpoint by spotify which is a premium
streaming service
we will connect to that and we will look
at accessing some of the music tracks on
that website
okay so we've got the application
created here
so let's minimize this and we'll open up
our editor all we've got to say is file
and open folder
and let me go to the react.js demo
folder so this is the music app
that got created and that's exactly what
we're going to open up here
so we'll navigate to that folder
it's called music app we'll select it
and
have it opened in our application so you
can see here we've got a note modules uh
folder this has all of the pre-installed
packages that
make up the react.js library we've got a
folder called
public which will have the index.html
file that's the root
file that will uh launch so this is uh
the single page
application that we typically create uh
in
react you have a single page which on
which we're going to load multiple
components so that's the index.html and
then we could go and create
a folder structure currently if i open
the source folder
we can see a single app.js file and that
basically
is the file that has the source code in
javascript for a single component
which we are interested in adding on to
our page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding css file
uh and then we've got uh the a public
folder with
the index.html file which is going to be
uh
the root html file that launches uh
when we run our application so let's
uh go right up here and let's add
a link to an additional file so i'm
going to link
to another style sheet okay so we'd say
relationship
is equal to stylesheet and the type
is going to be text and css
and we will reference a file
called uh reset dot
css and this is a file that we look at
adding up later on it doesn't exist at
this point in time so
we will connect this and that's purely
for styling purposes uh so that we can
have
all of our css styles defined there next
thing i'll right click on the public
folder
we'll create a new file we'll name this
file as
reset dot css so that's going to be the
css file that will have uh
all of the css uh styling that we're
going to apply
and i'm going to use a ready code
snippet
for the css code so let me just
uh okay so i'll all i'll do is uh i'll
just go and pick up
a ready css file that i can just go and
use
if you look here i have a set of css
files that are created that
we're just going to use uh within our
application
and and that will avoid us spending a
lot of time on the styling so that we
can focus on our core concepts
uh which is actually learning how
component based architecture works and
how do we set up components
and have data communication between them
in react so
here is a file called reset.css
let me just fire up notepad and i'll
just open up this file
copy up the text here and i'm going to
just paste it
within my reset.css and if you look at
the code
very simple it's all about styling so
we've got
article aside etc all html5 tags set up
as display block so they take up the
entire width of the page
we've got some padding margin and font
size etc defined
we've removed list styling for the
unordered and ordered list
specifying the line height for the body
tag so basically uh
just styling up tables and uh so nothing
nothing to do with react here it's just
about simple
uh css that we've added up uh and now we
need to actually go in and dive into
create creation of the components that
we need
so let's right click on the source
folder so i'll select the source folder
we'll right click there
and that's where we're going to create a
new folder which is called
components okay so this is the
components folder now that's going to
hold
all of the components within it within
the components folder let me create
another new folder and i'm going to call
it app and this is exactly how
we are expected to structure all of the
code that we have
now i already have a css and app.js
which are the root components that were
added by default and
all i'm going to do is i'm going to move
them within this folder called app
okay so there's a proper segregation of
responsibility
and all of the code that deals with a
particular component
is all added into respective folders and
this really improves the maintainability
of the application
uh going forward now we'll need some
images
and i'm just going to make use of some
set of images that i've downloaded from
the web
and uh here are the set of images that i
have
so i'm just going to copy all of them
and we'll come to
a music app and we go into the
components and app folder and that's
where we're going to add all of the
files and you've seen
all of those image files getting added
so these are just icons and images we're
going to use for our music tracks
inside our application now uh let's move
to the app.css file
and uh this is where we've actually got
uh so the app.css file is the file
that's going to style up
the all of the style rules that we've
added
into the root app component and this is
what we'll have to
revamp so i'll just get rid of this code
and
we'll probably add something for the
body tag the html tag
and the root element let me say hash
root
and let's set the height to a hundred
percent
coming to all of the html across the
page
we'll give it a font size of 10 pixels
and the h1 elements
let me give it a padding of zero point
seven seven and zero let's set uh
a background color give it a background
color
and just select some random color here
that can be applied then we'll set up
the text alignment
which is going to be the center of the
page we'll set up the font family
the font family is and this is part of
sans serif what else do we add let's add
up
the font size 1.88
and also the color so again uh these are
standard uh
html and css elements so
nothing really that has to be done that
is specific
to react here so again we are bringing
in the highlight
class so there is a class called
highlight that we will create later in
the uh
html view of this component and we'll
set this to a red
rgb component so combination of 46
113 and 238
okay so that's uh pretty much done let's
move on and also add up for the anchor
tag
let's add up some text decoration and
set it to none
so that the anchor tags don't come up
with those underlines
and of course we'll provide a color of
hash okay so a white color there
now coming to the h2 element for the h2
element
let's have font family and again i'm
going to use
so i'm going to use the font family that
we defined here
bracket and we change this to probably
1.55 okay now coming to the app tag
uh let me just save this and create a
copy of it
there was some content that i did delete
and i can simply go and make use of it
so i've just undone all of the deletion
so
this is uh something that i can't uh
if i can use something i can just
probably use it from the tag below so
let me start with a height here
and let's say the height of the header
is 100
of the app sorry not header padding 0
17 10
17 the background and i'm going to
change that
to background url so the background url
or let's say the background
image will have a url property
okay and that url is going to be
dot slash pg1 dot jpg so that's the
image that we've added
some in the previous step let's also
add background size
so we'll add background size and
set it to cover i'll also need
a background position to center
let's have background repeat which is
set to
no repeat so that we don't have the
image in a grid
format uh and then i would need this so
rid of it let's take up the font family
we'll maintain the same font family
let's use font weight the font weight
is going to be 500 and the color is
going to be
hash so that's a white color then we
come to
dot app.playlist so that's going to be
another class that we are going to use
dot but
app dash playlist is what we we're going
to name it
and let me say that the display
should be flex flexible display
and we will justify the content to leave
spaces
in between all right so that finishes
that bit and
now uh let's write up a media query
for the responsiveness of this page so
this is media for
only screen and max width is going to be
1 0 to 0 pixels okay and the class name
that we'll provide
later is obviously app playlist so for
this screen size
we would align all the items to the
center
and we change the flex direction okay so
we seem to be good with
the css for the app as of now
and that's the app.css that we created
let me save everything okay let's
check for any kind of uh
additional so all free of errors no
errors now
things are good in the app css and it's
time to move to the next step
of building this application uh now we
have to go
and add up the code for
uh the app.js file so let's
dive into the app.js file and this is
where
we will actually need to go and add all
of the code that
is required for the app component so all
the code that's relevant to
the app component we are going to add up
inside this
specific component itself which is going
to be obviously the
app.js file so we have skeletal code
which is import
importing the react library and let me
get rid of
the basic sample logo we'll have app.css
that's getting imported here
uh besides that lot of other files that
we'll have to get in
so uh let me import playlist
and this is these are the components
that we'll create as we go forward
and we're going to get this from the
playlist folder
and the component the file is going to
be called playlist so we'll add that
then we'll have to go and also import
search bar
so what we're basically doing is we're
going to split this app into different
components there's going to be one
component that manages
uh the playlist of all the tracks uh one
component
will uh act as the search bar so that's
the search bar
component that we're going to add so
searching for tracks will be managed by
this
we'll have another component that we'll
create that will get imported into the
root app component which is
a search results so this is going to
display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria
so search results slash search
results and finally we'll go and import
spotify that's the spotify service from
so we'll create a utility folder which
will hold
the code that connects us to spotify so
that's what we are adding up next so all
of the imports are done
one component that manages the search
bar so that's search bar
search results let me correct the
spellings there that search results that
spotify
and playlist so that's done now let's
move on to
the class that we're going to create
here so let's create a
class app that goes and extends
react dot component so that's going to
be a react.js component
so that's a constructor we discussed
about props
or properties and state management and
that's what we are
implementing we are using the super
keyword as a best practice
so that all the properties are
initialized in the constructor
and also we pass the values
up the chain to the super class which is
the root component class
now we're going to initialize a variable
called state that's going to manage
the state and we are interested in
tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll show that
as an array the playlist
would have different names so we'll just
call
ours new playlist that's the default
name
and we will also store a list of
tracks which is going to be playlist
tracks so playlist tracks is going to be
a list of tracks
and let's close this block okay and this
two
is going to be initialized within the
constructor so we'll add it here
and now we need to do the binding we
discussed uh
data binding so let's look at uh
creating a search
variable which will hold this dot
search dot bind and bind to the context
of
this very class so we are passing this
pointer
then we will create another variable
called
add track which to this dot add track
dot bind and all this functionality is
what we're going to add going forward so
right now
we're just setting up the bindings then
we'll have
capability to remove a track so we'll
say remove
track so remove track equal to this
dot remove track dot bind
and let's fix that
so and all of these two is going to be
initialized as part of the constructor
so that's where we're going to add it
then we need to update update the
playlist name so we need functionality
that will help us to update
the name of the playlist so
functionality that helps us to update
the playlist name so this dot update
playlist
name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind
and this is the pointer that we'll pass
i need to save the playlist so this dot
save playlist equal to this
dot save playlist dot find
and pass this and then i would also need
to remove
the track that has been searched for
from the playlist
so remove track search go to this
dot okay remove track search and
dot find and finally one last function
that
executes all of these which probably
will bind to
bind to this context so all the
declarations are done
in the constructor now we need to
provide the definitions
for all the methods that we actually
have added here so let me select this
tab inside and let's start with the
search function so
we'll define the search first it takes
some
variable value that it searches on and
then i'm going to say
spotify dot search i'm going to search
for
term dot then and that's an observable
so the moment it the search returns a
value
it it's going to call this callback
function
and that's when we want to set the state
and we're going to set the state for
search results to whatever is passed
by the system so the search results are
going to be returned
as a callback and that's what we store
as an updated state
now coming to the add track method so
let's scroll up
and we'll say add track and this will
take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this
dot the current state of all the tracks
that are there
in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to
find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist
then we would not want to add it if it's
not there
in the playlist that's when we would
want to go
and add it the triple equal to is an
equality operator that will check for
both
a watch value match and a match on the
data type
as well okay so if the track is already
saved to nothing if the track is not
safe just track the
track id because that is the track that
will uh
have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks
we'll use the javascript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks array and then update
the state
so we want to set the state of the
playlist
tracks and this is how your state
management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here
okay so the track has been added now
let's
talk about the remove track so that's
the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove
so let's let tracks equal to this dot
state dot playlist tracks those the set
of current tracks
that we have and let track search
another temporary variable equal to this
dot the current state
of the search results then let's take
the tracks array equal to track start
filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove
a certain value create a temporary
variable called current track use the
lambda operator
and if the current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id
which means this particular track is not
there
in the list okay so you need to remove
that and
again i have a method called as unshift
which will actually get rid of the track
in the array
and then we've got to so we'll search
whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is
then we simply want to remove it if not
we do nothing
so we set the state we need to update
the state of the playlist because the
track has been removed
so the playlist tracks will have to be
updated with this
tracks array okay then we go for remove
track search that's the next method that
also will take
a track as a parameter okay here we are
going to say
let tracks which is another temporary
variable we'll give it this current
state
of search results and then we are going
to say tracks
equal to tracks start filter
current track current track dot id
not be equal to the track dot id and
then
this is where we would want to say this
dot
set state and we'll pick up search
results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated
set of tracks after making the change
let's
remove this and correct it okay so
that's fine
so the remove track is now the remove
track and the remove track search is now
in place
let's add the do these functions which
actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this
dot add track okay so it adds the track
and then it removes the track from
the search criteria so the search
component which is managing searching of
the tracks that will go and remove it
from there after adding the new track
so that's a combined operation we want
to
execute then i've got update playlist
name which will take the name of the
track to update and this
dot set state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists
so here let me create a constant
variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change
we'll take all the track uris dot
state dot playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track
track dot uri so we actually want to go
and
now save this on spotify
so that's the reason we'll access
spotify's
safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name
comma track uris and if that is
successful we then go into a callback
so that's the callback anonymous
function where we're going to say
this dot set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called
new playlist so that's the custom name
that i want to provide
and the playlist tracks define
that this closes here okay so that's for
the update on
spotify now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript
and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view
and synchronize and bind the data
together so it helps from a
maintainability perspective so even
though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks
so we'll add the anchor tag and we say
href
is http localhost so that's the default
server port on which this application
will run
okay and we want to give it a custom url
name of musical file
so the h1 terminates will then say div
class name equal to app within that
this is how we're going to inject a
search bar
that's going to be the search bar
component
injected here and on search so that's
the custom event
we will call a method called search
so on search we just call we bind to a
method
called this dot search then we'll open
up another div
here we'll have class name equal to app
dash playlist and if you remember that's
exactly the css
class name that we refer to in the css
file we have
another component called search results
that we're going to inject here and
that's going to be search results
here search results will be equal to
this
dot state dot search results so that's
how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be
displayed with the data bound and if
somebody says add if
if i click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist
by calling binding to the 2ds function
and it will remove it from the
search results text box then we have
another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks will be
bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here
we started with defining all the
function declarations in the constructor
then we provided the function
definitions okay that's how
and this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist
couple of things we'll have to do is if
somebody changes
the name of the track so on name change
is going to be another custom event
where we have to call this dot update
playlist
name and we also have remove
functionality so to remove a track
we would say equal to this dot remove
track on save equal to this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this
so we seem to be pretty much on track
the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across
other components it's very similar to
the public access specifiers etc that
you provide
uh in other programming languages so
that's done
we've created our app component now
let's create
another folder under components and
we've got to define
all our various components here this
folder is
going to be for the search bar
so we'll name it search bar we'll add
two files within it the search bar dot
css okay and another file that we'll
need here
is search bar dot
js so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file
so we'll start with first styling search
bar we will say that the display
should be flex flex direction
should be column we want all the items
to be
aligned at the center so that's align
item center
then we'll add up padding so padding top
is going to be 6.94
rpm and margin bottom
is going to be 6.33 rem
all right now let's add up for the
search
bar so that's search bar we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be
287 pixels the padding
to be 0.88
0 the border should be 1 pixel
solid white the border radius will give
a slight rounded edge to give a web 3.0
look and feel so we'll set up the border
radius
then we've got uh margin bottom
so we've got a bottom margin that we
want to add up
then we have color so let's add up the
color
c3f so that's the color black then let's
add
text alignment of center and
let's add up a font size of one
rem okay so that's how we've set this up
let's add
the search bar input is
going to be so if someone focuses so
focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box
we change the outline to none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is focused so
that's the event
that we are looking for and then we
would have a button called
search button so on the search button
the cursor will set it to pointer
so that's the cursor pointer the width
we set it to
8.11 rem the padding
we are going to set up to 0.77
rem and 0 the border
radius we'll set it to 54 pixels so we
get a slightly
uh well-defined search button with a
nice little border
let's also add background color hash
one dp954
that gives me a color then i've got my
text alignment
let's set that to center then we've got
a font family let's set up the font
family to
the same standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans
serif family then we'll set up the font
size to 0.833
rem correct this and finally
we will need transition so all of these
are
basic css properties so that will add a
slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds so transition
background color we've provided what
else let me scroll up
uh let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove
in fact let's remove the border we we
would not want a border on the button
that would look
odd so i'll get rid of the border and
color we'll specify
as per our standard color that we've
been using
okay so that's the color we've specified
and then i've got
font weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button
we will register for the over event so
if someone takes
their mouse over the button that's the
over the
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want
the background color to
change so it will appear to have a
slight little glow there
a mouse pointer moves over the button
okay so that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css
file for the search bar and we obviously
now
need to go and get the code in
for our search bar component and that's
exactly
what we are going to do next so let's
start with
setting up the code for the search bar
first thing let's go and import react
from react next thing we would want to
do
is import the search bar
dot css file then we define
a class called search bar which
extends react dot
component we define our constructor and
we go and pass these parameters to the
base class
we also define the state we'll just need
one variable here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and
then let's say this dot
will define a function called handle
term change
which is going to be equal to this dot
handle
handle term change dot find
so that's going to be the first function
then a function that will do the
searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function
and we'll have it bind to this then
we've got
this dot handle enter
so the moment we enter into that search
text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is
handle term change we'll pass it a
system defined keyword of
event this dot set state
and for the term we will use the event
keyword
we will get the value that is there
inside that text box the moment the
search term
the user is entered changes so the
search criteria changes we trap the
updated value then in the search
function we will update
the local property props dot on
search okay so we'll access the on
search
and pass it the updated term
and then we got the handle enter
on which we're also going to pass the
system define
event keyword so if there's any data
flowing along with the event
we are interested in it in this case the
data is the key code that the user is
pressing
and if it is 13 that indicates that's
the ascii key code for
the enter button so if the enter is hit
then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where
we write our render method that's going
to render the html view
and we return the complete view here
so that's the view now that we want to
return let's say diff
class name equal to search bar then
on the input text box we will use
placeholder
equal to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle
term change we already have an function
that manages that
and the moment keys are pressed and
released
so on key up is where we would want to
connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh
we're going to return a value i
shouldn't forget
to export the search bar okay so that's
what i want to export so we've exported
that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where
we'll go and close the div tag we've
added an input
and here is where i'm going to add a
button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment
the end user clicks on the button we're
going to connect it to
this dot search and we close
the button back within the pattern tag
search
so that completes the render function
so in the render function again let's
run through all of what we've written we
started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor
passing props to the super class
constructor
we created state we set it to
a value of term and null so the state
currently we defined as term then we
said handle term changes search and
handle enter should be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render
render we said is going to return to us
the html that we've specified okay we
dumped all the
html that we want this component to
return to us
so on change and on key up are two
functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change
and handle enter then we added a button
where we registered for the click event
and connected it to this dot
search so all the three functions that
we
had actually written so two things we
have completed now
in the app class okay if you look at the
app class
we've actually defined a set of
functions here that deal with
the playlist and adding applications etc
adding tracks
removing tracks then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also
we have specified a set of functions and
all the functions that we defined we
have taken care
to structure every component separately
so the search component is doing
something
completely different which is managing
the search bar we have the core
the root app component in which we have
imported all of the other set of
javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire
application is now structured so
and that's the core uh concept when
you're working with
react where you would actually have
every separate
uh block of code or every separate
functionality
handled in a different component
altogether
so we've completed the search bar
component as well so
two components done and two components
good to go so we've got to start up on
the next set of components that we will
need to build
and the next component is the track
component that will manage individual
tracks so a new folder
a new file called track.css
track dot js so that's going to manage
uh
the tracks for us so let's start
with dot track we would say display
is flex align items
center border bottom 1 pixel
solid rgba 256
256 256
0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use
all of these classes uh when we write up
the html view
we'll add a padding here of 0.5 we'll
set up a font
size of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.25
s border of 0 pixel
and a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in
track another class track action and
if we hover over this class we want
the gb values change to 265
265 2 6 5 5 as the last parameter so
that's the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with
we'll add the flex parameter first
display flex and
then flex direction
is going to be column let's have
justify content set up as
center and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track
information let's have another track
information and the h3 tags
nested inside that for all the h3 tags
nested inside that we'll need a margin
bottom
of 0.22 yep
finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size of 0.83 rem
and a font weight
of 300 and a color as well that we'll
add
so let's add up a color here rgba
2 6 256
256 256 and
0.8 okay so that's uh that's in terms of
the css
and let's move to the track
and we'll move into the javascript file
so let's move into so let me take
what we added in the search bar i'll go
to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change
to add track so add track
change this to add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say
uh this dot props so we'll modify
this this dot props
dot on add this dot
props dot track and then we have
the remove track so that's going to be
the remove
track function this function is not
required
so this dot prop starts on remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove
we'll add up another function called
render
action so this is going to be a function
uh that we are defining called render
action
and in this we'll just check if this dot
props dot is remove
if this dot props dot is
removal so in that case we would want
to return so this is a view action
method that we are adding which is going
to go and add this button
with a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for
and this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is what it's going to
map to let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function
so that's uh the closing button tag okay
so the closing button tag
is what we've added there and
the binding is what we have done to this
dot remove track and
we will terminate this here so now the
render action
uh let's also have the return
here and we just add up
the button and this is going to
add track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic
uh in nature so we have two buttons that
are going to be added
this button with the hyphen is going to
remove the track this button
uh with a plus sign is going to add the
track
and you can actually see how simply it
was done in a render action function so
the render action function actually
helped
with checking that if uh
on the value of the props and if the
user
depending on the action performed you
will actually be able to
remove a track or add a track from the
existing
playlist okay and then uh the class name
here
is now going to be track the class name
for the enclosing div inside it so let
me get rid of this the class name for
the enclosing div
here is going to be track
dash information within it we'll add
h3 we'll bind to this dot
props dot track dot name so the name of
the track
is going to get bound here then in the
paragraph
we will find to this dot props dot
track dot artist and
with some gap this dot props dot
track dot algo so that's what uh
we've data bound to and then let me add
an iframe
and iframe allows us to very easily
inject some content into the page within
a small
embedded window the source parameter of
the frame
is going to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash embed
slash track and close this so that's the
spotify
stream that we are going to connect to
and this dot
props dot track dot id
so that's the track id the width
is going to be 300 the height
parameter this the height parameter is
going to be 80 of the iframe and
the frame border is going to be
zero and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity
we'll say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here
and we can also have the title
set to preview so that's uh with the
iframe
okay at the bottom is where we would
want to
so this could be an empty element and we
can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part
and then here i'm just going to say this
dot
render action so we call the render
action method
uh which will actually give us plus
minus button
to add and remove a new element
okay and that's what we can actually go
and add up there
so let's check now whether uh all that
we've done
is good to go fine so everything looks
good uh in terms of the track component
now
and we have all of the functions in
place
it's now time to jump into the uh next
component that we would require
after the track component and that's
going to be
the track list so this is going to be a
list
component that will comprise of a list
of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this
track list and that's going to have
track list css and it's going to have
track list dot js so that's the
track list uh component now which
we're going to go ahead and use and the
css
we don't need much so let's just say
track
list and we just provide a width
of 100 okay that's all we need
uh in the css so let me add this
in the css file save this and come to
the
js file now which is going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again
i'm going to say import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and we also want to go and get
track because this component is going to
be made up of a
collection of tracks individual tracks
so we want to get this from
track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot component we just need the
render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself
it simply goes and returns a list of
individual tracks so this class name
is going to be track list
and we'll find to this dot props dot
tracks dot map create a temporary
variable
and this will go and return
the track component which is going to
bind to individual track
data the key is going to be track dot id
so the key is going to be track dot
id and on add on adding a new track
we want to bind to this dot properties
dot and we already have on add defined
so that's what
we'll connect to we add up my base
bracket here okay and then
we would also need is removal
equal to this dot props
dot is removal and the on remove
will do this dot prop start
on remove so that's for the track
removal and so we've got our
track list uh oh yes we'll have to go
and uh close the tip tag correctly
and also we need to go and export
so we'll have to go and export the
track list so we've got one more
component done which
is track lists and let's move on to the
next component now
so we've got app which is root we've got
the search bar that takes care of
entering the search criteria we've got
individual tracks that are searched and
returned and we've got a track list that
manages a set of
track records so the track is more
relevant to the playlist and then we've
got the search results also to manage
once we search for some set of tracks so
we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have search results
dot
css and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results.css and
js
and here in the css file we'll keep it
simple for the search results so we say
search results
we'll set up the width of 50 percent
we set up the height of 950
pixels we'll say overflow
y is scroll we'll say
padding is zero point
rem background color will be rgba
95 23 23 0.7
and we will use the box model so we'll
provide a shadow
dropping shadow of zero for pixels
to pixels to pixels ash
and then let's add a scroll bar
so webkit and mozad are the constants
specific to mozilla and chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc
or properties that are specific to those
individual browsers
that's the reason we use those constants
and then
we'll also add a media query that
if it goes with a max width
one zero two zero pixels in that
case dot search results
width is ninety percent
with a margin bottom of two
okay so we're going to add the hyphen so
it's hyphen webkit
scroll bar zero pixel width
and we've set transparent background so
that's that's about it with
the css i need to get to the
js file now let's move to the search
results
js file and that's where we will now
have to go and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take pick this up from track
list
add it up here this will be search
results and we need the results will
return to us a list of tracks so we'll
have to get
uh track list this will be track
list and i'm just going to return
class name will also be search
results so that's the component and this
is going to export out search results so
it's accessible across
other components then we've got h2 with
results
let's go and create tracked list with
a set of tracks and we will bind it to
this dot
props dot search results and
on the on add we are going to bind to
this dot props dot on add so we already
have that
so that uh basically completes
search results and that leaves us with
the last component which is going to
manage
the playlist for us so we'll add up a
new books we'll add up a new
folder in components and that's going to
be
playlist and within that we will have
a playlist dot css and
a playlist dot js so that's our
playlist component now that we're going
to work with
and the playlist component is uh we'll
first set up
the css that we will need to add up to
the playlist
and i'm just going to pick that up
from my code snippet so that's
my playlist and let me get all of that
css here so that's uh just this
css for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css
let me get uh into the js file and
that's where we will need to go and add
all of our component code
so again let me go to the track.js
the track list rather let me get this
and add it out here we'll make some
small changes
this is going to be playlist i need to
import
the track list because the playlist is
going to contain
a list of tracks this is going to be
playlist and let
me here this will be playlist
and we'll leave this for later okay let
me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here
and just one function that we will need
here
which is handle name change you know if
i need to change the name of the
playlist
so handle name change and that's exactly
the function that
we will need to write code for so that's
the event
and this dot props dot
on name change that's when we'll say
event dot target dot
value so we get the updated playlist
name
coming to the render we now need the
input
input is going to be on change
equal to this dot handle name
change the default value
we have already provided with a
hard-coded value which is
new playlist so that's the default value
if not provided then we'll just pick up
the default value
then we've got track list so track list
is what i will add the tracks i'm going
to bind to
this dot props dot playlist
tracks so we're going to bind this to
playlist
and here we will say is
removal equal to true
and on remove equal to we'll bind that
to this
dot props dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist
dash save that's what we've added in the
css
click equal to this dot props dot
on save and here we're going to say
save to spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export
playlist and not track list
now we need to uh do a quick lookup
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in and create an
id it takes us to our dashboard uh
that's where we can create
a sample application the name of the
application
will be musico file okay and
we'll say that we're building uh some
kind of desktop app for example
for which we want to uh connect this to
and we'll also need to provide
uh so we'll say next refresh the
dashboard
so it's uh asking me for a login so let
me login once more so moment i login
that's going to be
description and i'll say maybe this is
why i need it
i'll say no not commercial integration
agree with the terms and conditions
and we will say submit and that's the
application that has got created and now
i can say
edit settings and the redirect url here
is what is important so it should accept
connections from http localhost
3000 that's the port on which we will
host our application
okay and we'll say save okay so that's
uh
now there's a client id that is
generated here for my app which is
unique
so i'll just copy that up let me come up
to my
application under the source folder i'm
going to add a new folder
called util and under that a new
file called spotify.js so we will start
with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util
folder the first line of code is going
to
define a client id variable that equates
to
the client id that we will generate on
spotify
so this is going to be the spotify
generated client id which is a unique id
associated for
the developer to connect to the spotify
api and we will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable
that we'll create is the redirect url
or let's call it redirect uri
and that will equate to localhost
colon 3000 which is the port and we'll
create
another variable called the access token
let's also create another constant
variable
called spotify and this will work like a
function expression
so we'll equate it to a function called
get access token
and we will say if access token
is true then return the access token
now let's declare a constant variable
called
access token match which will be equal
to
window dot location dot
href dot match and
we will say this is equal to access
token which will be
equal to and we will give a rejects
expression to do
a pattern match ampersand so that we can
actually get
into the url and extract the token
information from that
and hence the patent match is crucial
here
another constant variable called
expires in match equal to
href window.location.href.org match here
we will
read the expiry information using
another regex expression
from the url ampersand asterisk so
that's the second constant variable
we've created
now we will say if access token
match and expires in match
in that case the access token
should be equal to access token match
of one then we create a variable called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from
the expires in match that's done
then we will say window dot set timeout
and we are going to say access token
equal to comma expires in
multiplied by thousand then we will say
window dot history dot push
state and we will say access token
we'll pass the second parameter as null
the last parameter as
slash and close this and we will return
access token else we will say const
access url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash authorize
client underscore id equal to
dollar client id ampersand response
type equal to token ampersand
scope equal to playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now
get generated so we will say modify
dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect
uri so we have constructed the url now
that will go out
and get generated in the browser and
here we are going to say window dot
location
equal to access url then we'll add the
search
criteria function which accepts a term
as a parameter to search on
here we will say constant access token
equal to spotify dot get access token so
we get a reference to the same access
token
return we call the fetch function and
we're going to pass
https api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash search question mark that's the
query string
that we will add type equal to track and
ampersand
g equal to dollar and we will pass
term comma as the header information we
will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the pairer
is dollar access token dot then
response return response dot
json dot then so the return of this
function once it completes
we will then call the next function so
json response and then we will say
return response dot json
after that another then block so we'll
now say
jsonresponse and if
not jsonresponse.tracks
in that case we will return an empty
array
else we will return json response
dot tracks dot items
dot and we will pass we'll create track
as a variable with a lambda expression
and we'll create a temporary json object
with id
and that's where we want to associate
track dot id
that was returned as the search result
the name
is going to be associated with track dot
name
the artist is going to be associated
with
track dot artist of zero dot
name the album is going to be track
dot album dot name and the uri
we will equate track dot url so that
completes uh
this block will open the next and we
this will be the save playlist which
will take the name
and the track uris and here we will
check
if not name or not
track uris dot len in that case
we simply return out of the code and
then we declare
a constant variable called access token
which will be equal to
spotify dot get access token so we get a
reference to the access token
we then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be taller access
token
and we'll create a user id and now we
will return
the fetch result where we will pass
https
api dot spotify dot com
slash v1 slash me so that's the url
comma headers will be the header
information then we call the then
function declare response as a variable
use the lambda expression and access
response dot
json we use the then block to declare
json response here we say
user id equal to jsonresponse.id
and then we return fetch https
api dot spotify dot com
slash v1 slash users
slash dollar of user id
slash playlist so this is how we've
constructed
the urls manually here we will say
assign
headers to the headers variable we'll
assign
method as host so the data is sent as
part of the body
and not as part of the url and
as the body we will say json.stringify
to convert
this parameter name and then
we will generate a response variable
to response.json and
then we'll create jsonresponse
with the lambda operation we'll create a
constant
playlist id which is equal to
json response dot id we will return
fetch https api
dot spotify.com v1
users dollar user id
slash playlist slash dollar
again we are constructing the url so
playlist
id will be replaced here then we will
say tracks
and close this comma and here again
we will say headers would equate to the
headers
variable be constant headers
and this goes here
okay everything fixed now so here we're
going to say
headers should equate to headers
and the method is going to be
post and the body
is going to be json.stringify
uris track urls and we close this
we close this block we close this block
and we close this block so that
completes our code
of course one more thing we'll have to
do which is export this class out
so export default spotify
and that completes the code for the
spotify.js
which is part of our utils class
so let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is uh the client id
that will have to exactly match so i'll
copy this client id
and provide it here so that's the client
id uh
that we actually need and we could also
store it out here so that's the
client id and that's the redirect url
that we've also
defined there and we just create an
access token
if your access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match
from uh the moment we try and connect
with this particular url and you can
look here that this is the access url
that we are trying to connect with
okay with the client id and post fixed
with
the redirect url right and then i've got
a simple search function
which returns an observable so we try to
fetch
data using the search term that we
provided
okay we try to fetch data using the
search term provided
if we are successful we get a response
of the data and
accordingly we'll iterate over the json
response and get a list of tracks out of
it and do a mapping of this json object
to the track id
name artist information album name etc
and here uh just like a data access
layer very similar to a data access
layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist
and i've got search so these are the two
functions which
will go and connect to the spotify
service by using
this client id and it will allow me to
access that information in terms of
returning
a stream of json data and will then
allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we actually need
to
start up the application so i'll go to
the terminal and
rather let me go to view and bring out
the
terminal so this is the integrated
terminal that's there
in the tool and it just opens powershell
from which you can actually
fire your commands so i'm going to say
node package manager npm
start to actually start up this
application
so that's going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access
so i need to grant access to that port
3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that
you can actually see here so this is the
search
bar that we actually had okay then we
had the results
we had the playlist now the results is
going to consist
of a set of tracks which are maintained
by the track list and then you can take
individual tracks with the plus and
minus button and add them
into the playlist okay so that's how
it's typically going to work
okay so as you can view here i am just
going to search for an artist
and we click on the search button it
goes to spotify
tries to connect there and says that i
need to agree to the terms and
conditions
and i've just agreed to that so the very
fact that it actually
uh gave us a confirmation
link the moment we try to connect and
execute our application
that's proof enough that it actually
went and connected
to the service there and tried to return
a value to us
so this is what we did we just added an
artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons
getting added on the fly so that was the
render action
these are buttons that got added onto
this list of tracks
dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist
okay as in when i click here so i've
added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file application
and that i've created here in the
developer's portal of spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank
so now i'm going to click on save to
spotify okay and
that clears the playlist so let me come
here
and now when i come out here we saw
that it actually got successfully
connected
out here now i'll have to log in to so
this was the development app that we
actually created on the developers
portal of spotify
now we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and
it says do you want to launch the web
player and all that so let me click on
that
so it just launches and can you see here
this is the new playlist
that just got added right and there were
four songs
that i'd actually added to the playlist
and you can see here those four songs
have got added out here okay so i can go
here
and i can delete this playlist and say
i want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now
i'll go back here i'll add two tracks
and i'll say save to spotify
so that's how you actually saw that the
new playlist you can see the new
playlist has come back here
okay and that's the playlist the
playlist has got generated again and
that's the new playlist
that got created and we deleted it
but it still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity
that we successfully created with this
react app and the core concept of the
react app was breaking it down
into components which is the search
component
then we created the track component we
created the track list to maintain a
list of tracks
uh then we created the search results
which will generate a list of results
which further contains a track list
and this is the embedded iframe which
gave us the response
which is scrollable here and you can see
that the iframes we created allowed us
to scroll
this uh with this embedded web page
inside the iframe container
so with that i hope we've been
successful with explaining the
concept of component based design and
architecture with react and how
important it is to create individual
components and the benefit of that
being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability
wherever you want the same feature to be
implemented on the page you can just
inject that same component and the same
implementation and the same features can
be reused so it promotes reusability it
promotes flexibility to change
it isolates your change request to
single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole
finally we'd like to extend a big thank
you
for viewing our content and i hope this
has
added value to your learning journey and
has
been instrumental in supporting you and
assisting you
with learning the right skills and
acquiring the right skills
on this technology to help extend and
grow
your career path and your journey way
forward
in the industry thank you so much and a
big thank you on behalf
of the city learn platform
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here